a group of 37 major american companies
and their leaders are coming together to
advance
economic opportunities for black
americans this coalition is called
110 why well over the next 10 years it
seeks to train
hire and promote one million black
americans that's the 110 who do not have
a four-year degree
into quote family sustaining jobs
partner companies include it's a
well-known group
american express delta airlines nike
target and walmart
first on cbs this morning co-founders
ken frazier and jenny rometty join us
now
ken is the ceo of merck and jenny's
executive chairman of ibm
good morning to you both you know this
initiative was just announced moments
ago so really appreciate you coming in
to share the details with us ken i'd
like to start with you about the
selection
criteria because i think many people are
fascinated that you don't necessarily
have to have
a college degree here
yeah so first of all good morning and
thanks for having us you know the
challenge that i think
many americans face and it affects black
americans
in a particular way because you know
only about
20 percent of black americans have a
four-year degree
is that many times companies require
four-year degrees for
the kinds of jobs that really do not
require a four-year degree
and so what we're trying to do is we're
trying to urge companies to take a
skills first approach rather than a
credentials
approach which will eliminate some of
the systemic barriers that
african americans have faced and if you
look at the data
you can see uh that there's a huge
disparity between
opportunity and wealth between black
families which have on average about
four thousand dollars and white families
that have about a hundred and forty
thousand dollars
that's what we're trying to address i
know ken i saw those numbers this year
i i honestly honestly i thought it was a
typo and it's been my experience
to be honest with you that book smarts
don't often
translate to skills or even your
intelligence in some cases
but jenny rometty i want to know exactly
right yeah you've gotten a lot of
prestigious companies to sign on board
what was your elevator pitch to them to
entice them
well i think the elevator pitch is that
we all need talent
and there's a large talent pool in
america we're not tapping into
and as ken said skills first and we've
been at this at ibm for almost eight
years and we're a great proof point of
this
um now after working hard and adjusting
our job requisitions which is one of
those structural barriers to address
we no longer require a four-year degree
to start for 43
of our jobs now 15 then were people that
represented the skills first group
and as i was sharing with ken we've had
our first phd now out of the group
so this idea that it is not a lack of
talent it's just a lack of
access and so one of these structural
barriers we remove
is giving them a new pathway into our
companies and i would just
add to something ken said that it isn't
even just a job
we really believe these can be upwardly
mobile careers
and therefore we really do break a cycle
can can you've said uh
that we've been at these defining
moments before and we've let them go by
that with that essentially corporate
america has made what you call
pacification
payments how is this moment different
and is it really different do you
believe
i do believe it's very different i think
that uh this group of
ceos are very interested in not passing
the challenges the historic
challenges on to the next generation i
think we also recognize
looking forward uh that this is going to
be a more diverse country and the
workforce is going to be more diverse
and if we're able to take advantage of
all the talent in our
country we can strengthen our economy
and we can eliminate some of the
racial and social barriers that we worry
about in this country
so i think it is different i think this
is a moment in time
i think after the whole george floyd
killing these conversations were
happening across
kitchen tables as well as boardroom
tables i'd like to think it's different
this time ken
you know this seems very intentional and
specific jenny rometty this question for
you are you worried about being accused
of excluding
people well if we view this as a startup
and while we're starting with black
americans we are also going to move to
other underserved groups but like any
startup you have to start somewhere
and we're going to start with a group
that we believe should be at the top of
our list
and i must say this idea that we're all
going to do what we can do best which is
provide economic opportunity
and jobs and i think when we do that for
one group
it actually benefits all of them because
those barriers will remove
we remove them for everyone all right
jenny and
and ken frazier thank you so much listen
this certainly warrants further
conversation i hope that we can do this
there's so much more to unpack here
we thank you very much for starting it
off with us this morning